Charlie Metzger '12:
I had the incredible opportunity to take a freshman seminar with Professor Cornel West,
so for three hours a week 15 other freshmen and I spent time with probably the most influential
Charlie Metzger '12:
African-American public intellectual in the world. It was just a mind-blowing educational
experience. I think the most uniquely Princeton experience I've had so far didn't actually
Charlie Metzger '12:
happen here. It happened on the other side of the world in Vietnam. I had the chance
to study in Hanoi last summer for seven weeks on a program run by the Princeton Institute
Charlie Metzger '12:
for International and Regional Studies with 14 other Princetonians. We went with
three professors -- one of which is a huge superstar in the East Asian Studies Department, and
Charlie Metzger '12:
the other of which is a Princeton alum who single-handedly reopened the embassy in 1995.
It really made me realize how incredibly lucky I am to go to a school like this where opportunities
Charlie Metzger '12:
like that can happen.
Paavana Kumar '10:
One of the reasons I came to Princeton was to be able to concentrate on music more, and
to be able to hone my skills as a singer and a pianist. Things I've really enjoyed have
Paavana Kumar '10:
been to sing with the Glee Club and the Chamber Choir. They've had really great performance
opportunities. I've been able to sing in Richardson Auditorium here and to tour other
Paavana Kumar '10:
places like Buenos Aires. I've also toured to Ireland and Los Angeles with my a cappella
group, which was a really great experience. The most exciting experience I've had really
Paavana Kumar '10:
has been to do with the independent work I've been able to do, which I know is something
that sets Princeton apart from other colleges. So for me I came to Princeton because I wanted
Paavana Kumar '10:
to study more in the fields of literature, in the fields of language. I'm also really
interested in music, so I'm writing a senior thesis that has to do with the kind of intersection
Paavana Kumar '10:
between music and literature, and music as narrative strategy, which is really kind of my dream thesis.
Eric Plummer '10:
The J.P. and the thesis -- those two projects are where you figure out what you're passionate about.
Because you can't write a hundred pages or 30 pages for your J.P. on something
Eric Plummer '10:
that you don't care about. That's when you learn the most about yourself, when you're
writing your J.P. and your thesis. The happiest surprise was just that the people are who
Eric Plummer '10:
they are, I guess, that I wasn't coming into an environment where I was the only person
like me. It's a school for all of us. Because you can get the books and the education at
Eric Plummer '10:
almost any institution in the country, but at the end of the day, the people that Princeton
picks to be here are some of the brightest, most talented, people who help you become a better you.
Ana Gonzalez '11:
Participating in a civic action service trip run through the Pace Center. I applied and
was accepted to participate in a trip to the Pine Ridge Reservation in South Dakota.
Ana Gonzalez '11:
It honestly was one of the most amazing experiences in my life. There was no other place I would
have rather been over fall break. It was beautiful to be able to apply so much of what we learned
Ana Gonzalez '11:
in our classrooms here at Princeton. We're learning about theories, and we're reading
about people, reading about cultures, and to be able to engage a culture and a people
Ana Gonzalez '11:
and offer them some help. We did a lot of grantwriting proposals. It was a glimpse of
what Princeton hopes to prepare us for. I want to be more involved with the Pace Center
Ana Gonzalez '11:
now because of my trip.
Mike Yaroshefsky '12:
Running for student body president. It was a pretty remarkable experience, especially
the door-to-door campaigning. Being able to go and see 70 percent of campus is something
Mike Yaroshefsky '12:
that I otherwise would not have been able to do. One of the great things is that I had
a great group of friends who were able to support me through the entire campaign -- just
Mike Yaroshefsky '12:
tons of great people helping me out along the way, and that's why I was able to do
it, because I had the help and I had people behind me saying, "Just go for it, Yaro,
Mike Yaroshefsky '12:
you've got this, just do it!" Now that I've taken office, I feel a tremendous amount of
responsibility. I'm an engineer at heart, so a great perk of the job is that I get to
Mike Yaroshefsky '12:
see the inner workings of the student government and the University, and then I get to try
to make things run more smoothly.
Melinda Baldwin GS:
I think what a lot of people don't realize about graduate school is that it is a full-time
job, and if you don't treat it that way, it's going to be really hard to finish your Ph.D.
Melinda Baldwin GS:
Being a graduate student is really nothing like being an undergraduate. It's much more
like being an apprentice professor. One of the reasons I was really drawn to Princeton
Melinda Baldwin GS:
history is because of the very generous funding package that they're able to put together.
I liked that Princeton didn't think of us as cheap labor. I like that Princeton thought
Melinda Baldwin GS:
of us as people who were going to go on to careers beyond graduate school and realized
that the goal was to turn out people who would go on to successful future academic careers.
Melinda Baldwin GS:
And I thought that Princeton history did a really good job of recognizing why we were
there, what we wanted out of it, and how they could help us get there.